quand c'est les vacances à planoise la
plupart des enfants ne partent pas yves
tout simplement dehors
est ce que tu fais de ces journées on
s'amuse à faire péter des pépins puis
bon jour au balo tout ça tu t'ennuies
pas un petit peu non ça va 25000
personnes disent la planoise c'est un
quartier aussi important qu'une petite
ville mais sans problème c'est que ça
n'en est pas une
la zup dépens de besançon c'est un
ensemble des années 60 où il n'existe
pas de vraies structures de loisirs
résultat quand l'école est finie c'est
le désoeuvrement c'est l'ennui
les francas proposent des activités il
ya évidemment quelques associations qui
qui propose quelque chose aux enfants
ils sont rares et ça concerne quelques
dizaines d'enfants il ya tout de même
sept mille personnes de moins de 20 ans
planoise c'est beaucoup à côté de ça il
ya rien à côté de l'école il ya très
très peu de chances donc c'est une
évidence que l'ennui tourné par la
hauteur la mairie a donc pris des
initiatives et à la mise à la
disposition des jeunes écolos
mais sont bien fait tant de bruit total
peut-être
un concept et un budget de 134 me france
financera différentes activités
classiques mais les jeunes n'y trouvent
pas toujours leur compte utiliser l'un
des poids lourds frais les combats une
fois leur carte l'été puis des fois
cholet c'est banni quand une fois il
part tous les copains c'est cela qu'on
s'ennuie je fais et faya pc non puis
deux fois coach à des boulots on va
faire des tours là bas récemment un
habitant excédé par le bruit des pétards
faisait ce sur un jeune enfant
aujourd'hui à planoise on ne parlait que
de ça 6 éclairage doux
musique / remettre les pendules à
l'heure à planoise la petite délinquance
n'est pas plus élevé qu'ailleurs par
contre quelques fois la solitude pèse